c'était il ya près d'un an guillaume
jennati 24 ans employée dans une grande
surface se rend au vélodrome pour en
piste pour l'emploi son objectif trouver
un emploi dans sa filière de formation
l'électronique
c'est un plus un événement qu un
entretien d'embauché
je me suis préparé par rapport à ce que
j'avais fait pendant ma période de
débuter donc me souvenir un petit peu de
tout ce que j'ai pu apprendre pendant la
période
tout ce que moi je recherchais en tout
cas dans le domaine électronique après
son dut dans le domaine électrique il
n'a pas réussi à trouver un emploi dans
ce domaine suite à en piste pour
l'emploi il a été embauché directement
en cdi chez generali ce groupe dans la
filiale axt reid
il est aujourd'hui technicien électrique
là on fait un petit schéma de pour faire
différentes cartes donc là mois
principalement je dois faire une carte
une bande de l'aide là ici on fait tout
ce qui est schéma donc des cartes et
après on passera au labo pour contester
vérifier que les fonctionnalités sont
présentes
guillaume travaille pour différents
projets industriels ici une boîte
destinée au rangement de ski avec un
système électrique d'ouverture protéger
et automatique
le but c'est simplement avec une petite
carte de stations de ski on ne passe
devant un lecteur rfid et avec ce mot de
passe là il va nous donner
l'autorisation d'ouverture
je savais qu'il y avait un gros
potentiel après six mois voilà je savais
que c'était une perle rare
on a vraiment du mal en ce moment à
recruter des personnes dans l'ingénierie
électronique aux techniciens ou
ingénieurs est effectivement oui c'est
une perle rare
il a dépassé mes attentes pour son
évolution guillaume a comme projet de
suivre des cours du soir pour obtenir le
diplôme et le titre d'ingénieur chez
gennari ce groupe